hello friends and welcome to think  heroes new YouTube channel my name is  Dennis I just want to let you know that  we're gonna keep on doing our review  videos on movies and television shows  like Game of Thrones Breaking Bad  Boardwalk Empire also we plan on doing  more interview videos like we've done in  the past like with george RR martin the  creator of Game of Thrones and Stephen  tonight the creator of Spartacus and  also interviews with the cast of Vampire  Diaries Merlyn Spartacus and others but  in addition to those videos we also plan  on doing some different stuff like a  narrative and sketch based stuff like my  post-apocalyptic webseries nuclear  salvation and also a new comedy series  that's called geek land eeeh that  focuses on fanboys and fangirls that are  go a little too crazy thanks for  checking out the channel and please  subscribe that way we can keep doing  what we've always been doing and even  more videos thanks for checking us out  and talk to you soon